in stackdriver metrics are used to
understand the change of numeric values
over time and logs used to capture
specific point in time events but what
if you need to understand how those
events change over time you can use
thanks Revit to create metrics from logs
and I'll show you how this is a stack
dr. Google Cloud logs contain a wealth
of information but it's hard to analyze
trends without additional steps such as
exporting them to bigquery and using a
visualization tool
sacré our log base metrics allow you to
count records based on the filter you
can also track numeric values to easily
convert logs to metrics you can use for
analysis and alerting let's start with a
simple example we have an application
that writes errors out to logs now we'd
like to create a chart that shows us how
many errors we get and an alert that
lets us know if we get too many we can
create a counter metric from those error
logs simply by clicking the create
metric button and selecting counter as
the metric type the metric will count
the number of entries that match our
filter every minute the metric is then
available in stackdriver monitoring
under the logging slash user domain we
can create charts using in dashboards
and configure alerting policies using it
that was easy enough we now have a way
to use log base metrics to count how
many errors we see let's take a look at
a more complicated scenario in case of a
successful transaction our application
writes out a log message that tells us
how long the transaction took we're
going to track that value and chart
application latency here's the log
message with the latency recorded to do
that we'll create a distribution metric
to do that click on create metric it's
like distribution as the metric type and
specify a regular expression to extract
the numeric value we're after from a
field in the log payload the counter
metric we created earlier just counted
the number of entries that matched our
filter this distribution metric will
instead track the numeric value we care
about just like before
our new metric is available in stock
driver monitoring and we can create a
chart tracking its values over time we
can also use our log based metrics for
learning just like any other metric
available in stock driver monitoring by
using it as a condition and an alerting
policy one more great thing you should
know about log based metrics is that
they make it really easy to see the log
entries that we use to build the metric
values from a chart you can simply click
on view logs to see the logs for the
metric
while logs and metrics are often used
for different purposes you may have a
need to create metrics that help you
analyze log data sty driver log based
metrics both counter and distribution
allow you to do just that thank you for
joining me today and come back soon for
more this is the stack dr. stay healthy
out there
[Music]